butter
[Music]
I love Mission Impossible I love I love
them they are so smart they're
action-packed they're funny they're fun
you never know what's gonna happen and
they're just incredible the action is
always really interesting and creative
the sense of reality that you get with
Tom Cruise actually doing the stunts a
lot of movies nowadays you know it just
kind of looks like they shot in front of
a green screen I like stunts planes are
cool Tom Cruise is all right Tom Cruise
he is in a phenomenal actor he was so
good in Top Gun it made me almost want
to become a Scientologist so I'm
definitely gonna check it out I love the
mission Impossibles I mean they're
they're so much fun plus the fact that
um he does his own stunts my watch for
the stunts man does his own stunts can
we get you the mission impossible no I
don't like Tom Cruise
like a sign
[Music]
I don't think he can do anything else
well it's Tom Cruise he can do a lot of
crazy
he's superhuman I think
yeah he's not gonna be able to top him
hanging from an airplane and him
breaking his leg jumping from building
to building see his foot just Flint it's
like he can't beat that so I want to see
if he can top that I then go to space I
think fast and furious did that so
that's probably the next logical
conclusion it's just go to the moon go
tomorrow or something like that yeah why
not strive yourself to a rocket just go
to Mars oh gosh that sounds scary space
is always the next move on anything can
do it all I guess jumping out of space
you want to walk me through the
logistics of that I mean only he can
really explain it probably gonna go to
heaven if I jesus himself
that's how you close out the whole
mission impossible franchise yeah what
better way than Tom Cruise fighting God
himself you know die
survived everything you can't be just
just fall and oh look it's over oh
[Music]
wait let me see if I remember this it's
mission impossible one two three Ghost
Protocol
Rogue Nation
Fallout and then dead reckoning yeah
that's why I got this job
[Music]
can you name the subtitles of all the
Mission Impossible movies
number four was not Ghost Protocol that
was the last one
um what was the name of the fourth
Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol Ghost
Protocol correct can you name the fifth
Rogue nation and the sixth not off the
top of my head the Henry Cable ONE yeah
can you do the the Henry Cavill the the
arm the arm pump that he does
no after a couple of months I stopped
I'm sorry does Fallout sound familiar
I'm not gonna lie no
if you trip you
fall not in but pit
Fallout
and the new one dead reckoning part one
got it do you know how many Mission
Impossible movies they've made so far I
want to say this should be they made
four so far
it's like 10 doesn't it was like 10.
it's gonna be seven holy smoked okay
yeah I've not seen it you're behind on
them
wow what an impossible mission how many
impossible missions can they have you
would think after the third or the
fourth one that it would already be
possible
foreign
[Music]
thanks for tuning in to on the street
after you check out Mission Impossible
dead reckoning part one in theaters make
sure you go to rottentomatoes.com rate
review and comment right now let us know
your thoughts on the latest installment
of the classics by franchise no he does
not play a character called Tom Cruise
I've never heard anybody call them
anything other than Tom Cruise would you
climb the tallest building in the world
no what if my dog was trapped up there
and I said Anita can you go rescue my
dog I'll go buy you another one
guess you can get high five